Robin's birthday was yesterday I know
and so can't believe how old she is
happy birthday I can't believe it either
but George told me a wonderful thing
today yeah what'd he say he said his
grandmother told him this that you
should collect birthdays it's the most
precious thing lots of people collect
teacups and whatever collect birthdays
and he said his grandmother collected a
hundred five of them she was a really
good collector that sounds really odd
what he told I want you to collect your
birthday
the most precious thing that's what she
said the most VAT what is she talking
about birthdays she collects birthdays
it doesn't make any sense you know I
mean I love your grandmother but what so
many people are afraid of birthdays yeah
they you know they're fearful and they
quietly tiptoe past one of them she said
that's to be celebrated it's a wonder
but I mean she's just putting a spin on
something that you know and you'd and
then you encouraged George by telling
him you liked nothing better than being
stuck in an elevator with George's
homespun advice from his grand let me
tell you about my grandmother do you
have some time grandma to Kay has so
much wisdom is my grandma Nakamura my
mother grandma Nakamura has said